[Musique]
bonjour Bienvenue au club le village
donc là on se trouve dans l'entrée la
zone vraiment le hall d'entrée il y a
également un petit espace donc bar
snacking
pas terrain de squash donc il se trouve
juste au niveau de l'accueil passons un
peu à l'anglaise avec les tribunes pour
tout ce qui sera un peu compétition
événement que nous proposerons nous
voici à l'étage l'espace qui sera le
dédié à la fitness au cours collectif
[Musique]
attenant à l'espace accueil nous
arrivons sur l'espace raquette tennis
badminton donc en soi comme vous pouvez
le voir c'est deux terrains de tennis
qui sont modulables en terrain badminton
donc on a fait le choix de vous proposer
un terrain de tennis et quatre terrains
de badminton qui se trouve un peu plus
sur votre droite
on a deux nouvelles activités présentes
sur sur le complexe où nous avons trois
nouveautés flambant neuf de foot à 5
voilà c'est une discipline qui se passe
dans un espace clos qui se joue à 55
dans l'idéal et la deuxième activité
c'est le tennis padel parce qu'on se
retrouve en fait dans un espace
également clos fermé par des fenêtres
sur un format terrain de tennis avec un
filet au milieu le terrain est plus
petit qu'un terrain de tennis
l'ouverture du complexe au public c'est
mercredi 1er mars à midi
[Musique]